bassem vous êtes donc en place sur place
le pour cette manifestation elle touche
à sa fin c'est bien ça effectivement
pierre lahon se situe sur la place
fontenoy juste derrière lui ministère de
la santé juste en face du bâtiment de
l'unesco une manifestation à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats ils sont venus de
partout des quatre coins de la france à
l'appel de ces syndicats les personnels
soignants en colère ils sensibilisent le
gouvernement sur leurs moyens les moyens
qui manquent pervers du mans dans les
hôpitaux soient conditions de travail et
surtout sur une revalorisation de leur
salaire je vous propose d'écouter
quelques réactions des ces personnels
soignants
ça a été les mesurettes un clairement
aller 183 euros ne sait même pas une
revalorisation est un ajustement des
salaires une réelle revalorisation sont
était déjà d'une part de remonter les
salaires à 300 euros comment le
demandent et de les valoriser par la
suite le gel du point d'indicé toujours
d'actualité et avec l'inflation ces
mesurettes eux d'ici quelques années
mais on perdra les 183 euros aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment pour le ségur la
signature qu'a été effectué et quelle
excuse
le personnel du médico-social nous tiens
seulement à rappeler que nous sommes des
aides soignants et des âmes pop et ans
avec un diplôme reconnu par l'état
on peut travailler pour donner cette
exclusion elle a poussé les personnes
dépendantes
nous la fait le choix travailler dans le
médico social auprès des personnes
handicapées pour façon d'apporter une
aide supplémentaire de cinq ans
aujourd'hui on découvre que si on
travaille à l'hôpital on aura les 180
euros mais si on travaille dans le
mythique auditions les aura pas ce qui
va se passer aujourd'hui ça va engendrer
un désert non médico-social fallu
recruter personne ses condoléances du
cab et on se retrouvait celle qu'on nous
a donnée 180 euros par mois à partir du
mois de mars 2021
mais on peut nous donner 1000 euros par
mois ça tue des parts
on manque de moyens là cette semaine on
a eu quinze personnes qui sont baissées
72 heures aux urgences sur des brancards
faute de lits des gens des personnes
âgées des malades ils avaient aucune
notion savoir si ces jours ci faisait
nuit
ils faisaient leur alors besoin un peu
dans tout le monde sait qui n'a laissé
aucun lit à l'hôpital
alors ici sur cette place la
manifestation touche à sa fin quand vous
pouvez voir juste dernier à voir donc
les personnels soignants commence à
partir commencent à quitter cet endroit
la manifestation a débuté dans les
alentours de 14 heures c'était place
vauban dans 7e arrondissement pas très
loin de là où on se situe donc c'est à
une petite manifestation un petit
cortège pour se diriger
ici devant le ministère de la santé
beaucoup de prises de parole des
personnels soignants qui essaye de
sensibiliser un maximum le gouvernement
et puis les passants bien sûr sur leurs
conditions de travail sur leurs moyens
monsieur hirsch avait déclaré que les
personnes soignantes devaient se
sacrifier sacrifier leurs vacances de la
toussaint pour pouvoir travailler être
davantage en pleine deuxième vague du
coronavirus alors que jean castex le
ministre le premier ministre a déclaré
qu'une indemnité serait prévu une
indemnité de 110 à 200 euros bruts pour
à jour de congé non pris pour tous ces
personnels soignants une déclaration qui
n'a pas à calmer ni soulager ses
personnels soignants toujours en colère
qui sont bien décidés à continuer tant
que le gouvernement ne répondra pas
favorablement à leurs revendications
merci bassem chez vie pour toutes ces
précisions bassem chez vie en direct de
la manifestation du personnel soignant
et dans les rues de paris